well you have certainly created a lane
about what modern families look like on
your own and you you teased to us that
more babies were on the way you said the
stork's on the way the stork is on the
way can we how many babies are the stork
is the stork gonna drop off that would
take all the fun out of it if i just
gave you a number right now
okay well let me so bree we know bri tac
okay i'm watching you mad okay what else
you got all right so now abby dela
is having a baby is she having a baby
with you did she confirm that see this
is what i like to do just and it keeps
me sad because i never like to
generalize okay
so i allow the women in my life to kind
of share their news i got it on their
own i got it so because then it doesn't
make it look like i'm trying to get like
publicity and stuff for like so when
they're ready to speak on who and what
and where i support but for now i just
like i let them talk that's why i said
the stork is on the way we'll see how it
trickles down if my over
under was three okay
like would i be close safe to bed you
would become three you would be safe to
bet on three in 2022 i would be safe to
bet on three in 2022 yes okay i got you
well we know bree so i i have heard a
couple abby maybe maybe you would have
another baby with alyssa you never know
that's the other thing though and like
in all respect and you know jokes aside
it's like the process of having a baby
is so delicate yeah you know what i mean
and especially with someone like that
you kind of want to you know allow
nature to take its course and then when
it's time of course i want i want to
tell the world about all my children
it's just right i give the mothers the
respect to do it themselves and then
from there that process is like
it's all fun and games because as we
know we should allow women to speak on
their bodies and men should say nothing
well one of the things that the mothers
of your children have spoke on is what a
dedicated and present dad that you are
and that you always show up and uh you
just took your little queen charges
for the first time come on she was yo
powerful was all over the place once
she's so independent she doesn't like to
be held or being strollers or nothing so
she's like one and a half just like
taking over the zoo and then you had
your twins first steps yeah
i just said i like i love children i
want to
try to document everything like that i
do wonder if i'm just afraid you can ask
me yeah i do wonder how are you present
for all of this stuff how how can you
possibly be there
enough for everybody i got a time
machine okay i mean i'm being serious no
okay i mean and it's not as difficult as
people think it would be but i
understand because it's a very
unorthodox scenario but it actually i
mean i dedicate probably
my entire day to my children i get to
spend more time with my children every
single day because of my world and my
business my life what you can do i wake
up and i'm taking kids to school to
sensory classes yeah every where
everybody else probably has a nine to
five and they got other things to do so
the way my day is structured i'm i'm i'm
my own boss yeah so i i take my kids to
the office with me
as you see we're
doing stuff in the middle we're going to
the zoo in the middle of the week you
know what i mean you get to experience
certain things so based off of the way
school and summer and all that stuff
works out i'm present in everybody's
life every day so far so good i mean not
to say it's never gonna be perfect
but yeah but like i'm there like my day
is dedicated to my kids and anybody who
knows me it's like i'm up in the morning
i'm at little league practice every day
basketball boxing martial arts ballet
like we do it all and i lit i'm at that
stage in my life where that's my life i
love it and this stuff is cool too but i
can't wait to you know experience all of
this with them and bring your babies
here right right um okay so you also
have to know you have to schedule when
to be in the delivery room yes where
where and how did that one gets a little
cat right because that's my goal is and
and there is times and even in the
future there's my productions know like
yo when it's happening it's gonna happen
and like because i was you know from
touring and i was scared and all of
those things but you know god looks out
for me so far so good i haven't missed
one yet we talked to bree not too long
ago
and she said you know you guys work it
all out you do work out schedule
sometimes you guys go through the
assistant like he makes the schedule
work um we all can go through the
assistant to make sure it's on the
calendar if there's something important
now i wanted to talk about this michelle
i said mariah carey is not calling
anybody's assistant and i don't know
talk about that i'm glad you brought
this please do i think what she was
trying to say and you know we're in the
world of sound bite yeah clickbait what
she was saying is based off of what we
just said right my children have busier
schedules than i do so you so they give
you the schedule it's not like they go
to the assistant no no no it's like can
i you do do organization because
obviously we all do have things going on
throughout the day and with there being
so many people involved we got to make
sure we're on the same page because i
don't want to miss anything okay that's
the schedule we're talking about so no
one has to call my assistant to get to
me you had to break some news yesterday
so now i gotta get into it with you what
did i do now okay i'm gonna get into it
this is what you said you said you will
never have a love like mariah carey and
if you had the opportunity again you
would be there see let me give you the
content okay okay give me some context
before i go in first off it was a game
that was being played that i probably
shouldn't have been playing it was
called spin the block come on that's my
fantasy love that's somebody i will
always love like i know that i guess
because i'm a true romantic i will never
have a love like i have with mariah but
if i had the opportunity to if it could
be the way that it was i'm there
they were just naming random people that
you know the world has no known that
i've been involved with yeah and they
and i just was saying very nice things
about everybody involved but it wasn't
like it was like my please take me back
message it was like yo they whoever it
was and i tried to say positive things
about everybody that they showed and
that i truly feel that way i was gonna
say but off the camera you've told me
before that mariah was your dream girl
and that after being divorced you could
never get married again never but that's
why i say if you pay attention to what i
was saying i was talking about the
fantasy of it all and i was like yo if i
could have that same vibe
where i was at that state in my life and
that age of course i would do that all
over again but i'm like clearly there's
a lot going on in my life now it's
completely different from there but in
that game we were just playing spin the
block and that's what i said so that's
true everything i said is true all right
so i'll drill down on it were you saying
that you did want to get back together
that no i was playing okay spin the
block okay is the door still open at
least cracked at it i don't want me
you just show up with all my thousand
kids like hey
you did call that relationship a fairy
tale and for us
watching it was a bit of a fairytale
moment for you guys i remember when you
were at disneyland yeah we shut down
it's the perfect time where you may
continue your happily ever after with
true love's kiss
like it was the kids uh second birthday
prince charlotte oh and had a little
prince charming and monroe was little
cinderella mariah's big cinderella we're
in the castle it was amazing like i said
fairy tale memories there's no way that
i could ever have an experience like
that again and we're still so like close
friends best of friends great parents
together so i appreciate you know that
time in my life obviously we've all
grown and evolved and went separate ways
but it was still the like the biggest
fantasy of my life i almost like fell
over when i saw the video that mariah
just posted of your daughter
on the runway
did mariah call you do you ever hear
from her like if you say something do
you ever hear from her and like nick
what are you talking about it's what i
don't hear from her
like hello right i must have said
something again right